♪ ♪ ♪
(camera clicking)
Tyra: MODELING FOR A LIVING
CAN BE DAZZLING.
BUT A GIRL'S FIRST STEPS TOWARD
BECOMING A MODEL...
OOPS.
ARE NEVER EASY.
BUT YOU HAVE TO PUT YOUR BEST
FOOD FORWARD
TO MAKE IT TO THE TOP.
THIS CYCLE
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
THOUSANDS OF GIRLS TRIED OUT.
MODELING IS MY PASSION,
MY DREAM, MY DESIRE.
I'M AN ONLY CHILD,
I HAVE NO SIBLINGS
SO BASICALLY, IT'S ABOUT ME.
OKAY, LET'S GO.
Tyra: BUT ONLY A SELECT FEW GOT
FLOWN TO L.A. FOR SEMI-FINALS.
AFTER A WEEK OF AUDITIONS...
I AM A NURSE.
SO IF YOU HAVE SOME TYPE OF
WEIRD RASH GOING ON,
I CAN LOOK AT THAT.
CAN YOU SEE THE SHAKING,
THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
Tyra: WE PICKED OUR FINAL 14.
- YES.
- OH MY GOD!
(screaming)
Tyra: AFTER 12 WEEKS OF
COMPETITION,
CAMARADERIE
AND CONTROVERSY...
(screaming)
WE'VE GONE FROM 14 GIRLS
DOWN TO OUR FINAL THREE:
KAHLEN, KEENYAH AND NAIMA.
TONIGHT, SEE HOW IT ALL WENT
DOWN,
FROM REBECCA'S COLLAPSE...
(gasping)
OH MY GOD.
TO MICHELLE'S SKIN CONDITION...
Noelle:
IT LOOKS LIKE SHE'S PUTTING OUT
CIGARETTES ON HER FACE.
Tyra: TO MY TIFF WITH TIFFANY.
BE QUIET! THAT'S WHAT IS WRONG
WITH YOU, STOP IT!
I HAVE NEVER IN MY LIFE
YELLED AT A GIRL LIKE THIS!
PLUS, NEVER-BEFORE-SEEN MOMENTS
YOU WON'T WANNA MISS.
'CAUSE I'M JUST THE BITCH JUDGE,
GET USED TO IT.
Tyra: SOME GIRLS GET PASSIONATE.
AND ONE GIRL GOES OVER THE EDGE.
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ OH! ♪
♪ NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA
NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA ♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA
NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA ♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA
NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA ♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA
NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA ♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪♪
Tyra: FOR THE FIRST THREE CYCLES
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL",
I TOOK THE GIRLS
TO NEW YORK CITY
TO LEARN ABOUT
THE FASHION WORLD.
♪♪♪
THIS TIME, WE SHOOK THINGS UP.
YOU GUYS
ARE LIVING IN LOS ANGELES.
(cheering)
Tyra: I BROUGHT THIS GROUP
OF GIRLS TO THE CITY
WHERE I GOT MY START,
LOS ANGELES.
GREAT, I LOVE L.A.
SO LET'S STAY HERE.
I AM FROM HERE
SO I AM VERY UNHAPPY
THAT THE COMPETITION
IS NOW IN L.A.
TODAY, THIS IS
YOUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
(cheering)
TO KEEP THE GIRLS IN LINE,
I SENT MY OWN
FASHION POLICE SQUAD.
TOP MODEL JUDGES, NIGEL BARKER,
NOLÉ MARIN,
AND MISS JANICE DICKINSON.
BE AFRAID, BE VERY AFRAID.
Kahlen: I THINK JANICE IS
EXTREMELY SCARY.
SHE INTIMIDATES
THE CRAP OUT OF ME.
WHERE DID THIS COME FROM?
- Brandy: UM...
- Janice: THIS.
THE BEAUTY SUPPLY STORE.
Janice: WHAT ABOUT YOU?
WHERE'D YOU GET THAT,
WHAT'S THIS?
NO MORE TATTOOS.
Brandy: WHY ARE YOU SO HARD
SOMETIMES?
IF I'M NOT HARD ON YOU
IN THE BEGINNING,
AND IF I DON'T SAY, YOU KNOW,
I GOT NEWS FOR YOU, BRANDY.
IT AIN'T GONNA FLY
ON YOUR HAIR RIGHT NOW, BITCH,
BECAUSE THE MINUTE YOU GET TO
"VOGUE" MAGAZINE,
THEY'RE GONNA SAY "WHAT!"
SO I'M ACTUALLY
DOING YOU A FAVOR.
I'M JUST BITCH JUDGE,
GET USED TO IT.
Tyra: THERE WERE A LOT OF THINGS
THE GIRLS HAD TO GET USED TO.
OOH, OH, THERE.
Tyra: LIKE SLIPPERY PROPS.
UNCOMFORTABLE CLOTHING.
MY FEET HURT REALLY BAD.
THEY LIKE MADE ME SHOVE MY FEET
INTO THESE THINGS
AND I CAN'T EVEN WALK IN 'EM.
I'M SORRY, I'VE SHOVED MY FEET
INTO THINGS BEFORE
- BUT THIS REALLY HURTS.
- ALL RIGHT.
SHE'S A MODEL, SHE NEEDS TO
LEARN HOW TO WORK IT.
Tyra: AND LONG,
LONG, LONG HOURS.
BRANDY NOT FEELING IT RIGHT NOW.
WHY NOT?
Brandy: 'CAUSE I WAS WAITING
SO LONG, I'M NOT GONNA LIE.
Nigel: BRANDY, BRANDY, BRANDY,
YOU CAN BE AS MISERABLE
AS YOU LIKE
IN BETWEEN SHOTS,
WHEN YOU COME ONTO THE SET,
I'M LOOKING FOR SOMEONE THAT'S
GONNA WOW EVERYBODY.
Tyra: BRITA HAD BEEN WAITING
EVEN LONGER
TO START A MODELING CAREER.
I'M 25, I'M NOT 18, I KNOW
I ONLY HAVE A COUPLE MORE YEARS
BEFORE PEOPLE ARE GONNA START
THINKING I'M TOO OLD.
IT'S KIND OF A MAKE IT
OR BREAK IT POINT.
Tyra: BUT ON SET,
HER SELF-CONSCIOUSNESS
GOT THE BEST OF HER.
Brita: I'M WEARING COMPLETELY
SHEER UNDERWEAR, AND I'M SORRY--
I CAN'T POSITION TO BE
COMFORTABLE
WHEN MY SKIRT KEEPS FALLING UP.
SHE'S GOT A SIDE OF BEEF.
Tyra: THE GIRLS WERE DEAD TIRED
AFTER THE SHOOT,
BUT THEY CAME BACK TO LIFE
WHEN THEY SAW THEIR NEW HOME,
A LUXURIOUS LOFT
IN DOWNTOWN L.A.
YES, YES, YES...
OH MY GOD!
Sarah:
OUR NEW HOME IS INCREDIBLE,
IT'S MORE THAN WE THOUGHT.
THE NEW HOUSE IS BEAUTIFUL.
OH MY GOD.
Tyra: AS THE OTHER GIRLS STARTED
TO SETTLE IN...
WE'RE LIVING IN
MODELWOOD, BABY.
Tyra: BRANDY STARTED TO
COMPLAIN.
SORRY, Y'ALL HAVE PLANS?
I DON'T HAVE TIME.
I DON'T NEED ALL THESE
LIGHT FOODS, OKAY.
I EAT FAT, I EAT FAT,
I EAT FOOD WITH FAT, OKAY?
Tatiana: BRANDY, I'VE NOTICED
THAT SHE'S GRUMPY AT TIMES,
HAS A BAD ATTITUDE
AND IF YOU PUT
NEGATIVE ENERGY OUT,
IT'S GONNA COME BACK TO YOU.
WHERE'S OUR SUITCASES?
RIGHT THERE!
GIRL, Y'ALL GOING CRAZY.
Tyra: THE NEXT DAY, BRANDY
WOKE UP WITH A FEW KINKS
THAT SHE NEEDED TO WORK OUT.
OH MY GOD, THIS IS A KNOT.
YESTERDAY, THE MAN MESSED UP
MY HAIR, TEASING IT...
I'M LOOKING LIKE A FOOL.
NO, YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
I MEAN, COME ON.
OKAY, TOLD HER, JUST--
JUST TELL THE TRUTH.
THEY'RE GONNA GIVE ME
A MAKEOVER ANYWAYS.
BUT BRANDY WASN'T THE ONLY ONE
HAVING A BAD HAIR DAY.
IT WAS TIME
FOR THE GIRLS TO BE MADE OVER.
SARAH, WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU
A VERY PETER PAN
INSPIRED HAIRCUT.
MICHELLE, WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOU
ICE BLONDE GIRL.
MY BRANDY,
WE HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT YOU
AND WE'VE DECIDED, GIRL,
THAT YOU ARE... FIERCE!
AND WE AIN'T DOING
NOTHING TO YOU!
NADA.
Brandy: WHEN SHE TOLD ME
I WAS GONNA KEEP THE AFRO,
I WAS JUST LIKE,
WHY, BECAUSE I WANTED
A DRASTIC CHANGE SO BAD.
Tyra: BUT AFTER I TOOK A CLOSER
LOOK AT BRANDY'S HAIR,
I DECIDED SHE DID
NEED A MAKEOVER.
BRANDY, I'M GONNA HAVE
TO TAKE THIS OFF, PRECIOUS.
IT'S LIKE MATTED.
♪♪♪
JUST DO ME GOOD,
JUST DO ME GOOD.
Tyra: SOME GIRLS WERE EXCITED
ABOUT THEIR MAKEOVERS.
I'M READY TO LOOK HOT.
Tyra: SOME GIRLS WERE WORRIED.
YOU GUYS DO THIS ALL THE TIME?
WHEN THEY TOLD ME THEY WERE
GONNA CUT OFF MY HAIR,
I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS.
YOU'RE OUTTA CONTROL
WITH THE SCISSORS.
Tyra: BUT WHEN THEY SAW
THE FINAL RESULTS,
THEY ALL FELT FABULOUS.
- THAT LOOKS GREAT.
- INCREDIBLE.
I LOVE IT,
I LOVE IT-I LOVE IT-I LOVE IT.
EXCEPT BRANDY.
WHOA.
WHERE ARE THE EYEBROWS?
YOU KNOW, I CAN'T EVEN BE SEXY--
OH MY GOD.
Tyra: WHEN I CAME BACK IN
TO CHECK IN ON THE GIRLS,
I HEARD THERE'D BEEN
SOME ATTITUDE.
YOU PISSED ME OFF.
I DON'T APPRECIATE THAT,
AND YOU KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
THE NEXT TIME I SEE YOU
WILL BE AT JUDGING.
♪♪♪
AT JUDGING, IT CAME DOWN
TO BRANDY'S BAD ATTITUDE
AND BRITA'S BAD PHOTO.
YOU'RE FINE AS HECK IN PERSON,
BUT ON FILM,
IT'S JUST NOT WORKING.
YOU LOOK WORRIED,
YOU LOOK OLD.
Tyra:
BRANDY, WHY DO YOU ACT THIS WAY?
TO TRY TO BE...
I GUESS, REAL.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
BEING REAL AND PROFESSIONAL.
THERE'S SOMEWHERE IN THE MIDDLE.
IF YOU GO ON A JOB INTERVIEW,
YOU KEEP IT REAL?
AND SAY, "I'M TIRED, I BEEN UP
ALL NIGHT, MY BABY WAS CRYING.
AND WHAT YOU NEED ME TO DO?"
SURE, THAT'S REAL.
DOES ANYBODY WANNA HIRE YOU?
REAL IS HOLDING ONTO YOUR SPIRIT
BUT ADAPTING TO YOUR
SURROUNDINGS.
YOUR ATTITUDE ISN'T SOMETHING
THAT THESE JUDGES
WANNA BE AROUND.
BUT SOME OF THEM DO.
THE JUDGES STILL SAW POTENTIAL
IN BRANDY,
SO THEY DECIDED
TO SENT BRITA HOME.
THE NEXT MORNING,
THE GIRLS TOOK THEIR FIRST STEPS
TOWARD BECOMING TRUE TOP MODELS.
A RUNWAY LESSON FROM THE CATWALK
DIVA HIMSELF, MISS J. ALEXANDER.
(cheering)
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL, YAY!
Tyra: WHO CHEERED THEM
ON THROUGH A CRASH WALK
IN WALKING THE WALK.
BAM, HIT IT.
IT'S NOT EASY WALKING ON GRASS,
IS IT?
REBECCA ATTACKED
THE LESSON WITH CONFIDENCE.
I'VE BEEN IN JUST A FEW LOCAL
MALL RUNWAY SHOWS.
SO I JUST DO WHAT
FEELS NATURAL TO ME,
SO I AM FAIRLY COMFORTABLE
WITH MY BODY,
IN THE WAY IT MOVES
AND THE WAY I WANT IT TO MOVE.
Tyra: BUT OTHER GIRLS WERE
HAVING PROBLEMS.
MICHELLE,
YOU WALK LIKE YOU HAVE A BIT
OF BELL'S PALSEY
ON THE RIGHT SIDE
BECAUSE YOU WALK LIKE THIS.
♪♪♪
SARAH, PICK IT UP, PICK IT UP.
Sarah: GROWING UP,
I WAS THE TOMBOY.
I WAS VERY SKINNY AND STRAIGHT
UNTIL I WAS LIKE 16 YEARS OLD,
AND I JUST WORKED MY BUTT OFF
TO BE WHERE I AM RIGHT NOW.
I FEEL LIKE I'M AT THE RACES
AT THE TORTOISE AND THE HARE,
AND SARAH, YOU'RE THE TORTOISE.
Tyra: STILL SARAH FELT SHE WAS
FAR FROM THE WORST WALKER.
LET ME JUST SHOW YOU WHAT
I WAS JUST TELLING CHRISTINA.
- YEAH, I WANNA SEE.
- OKAY.
I LOVE IMPRESSIONS.
THIS IS HOW I WALK.
OKAY, GRANTED, IT'S NOT
THAT GREAT, BUT WHATEVER, OKAY.
SO I'M GONNA SHOW HERS.
I DON'T WALK LIKE THAT!
I'M JUST NOT THAT BAD,
I'M NOT THAT BAD.
Tyra: SARAH'S TROUBLES CONTINUED
TO DOG HER
IN THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT.
Woman: I DON'T FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE CONNECTING WITH ME.
I THINK YOU'RE LOOKING TOO MUCH
AT THE SET.
CHIN UP, CHIN UP!
I NEED YOU TO CONNECT
WITH ME FASTER.
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT,
I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE AS MUCH
POTENTIAL AS THE NEXT PERSON HAS
SO IT'S A LITTLE NERVE-WRACKING.
Tyra: ALTHOUGH, SARAH FELL FLAT,
REBECCA WAS UNSHAKEABLE.
Woman: I LOVE IT,
THERE YOU GO, YEAH!
Tyra: UNTIL A SHOCKING SURPRISE
AT JUDGING.
YOU NEED TO WORK ON
YOUR PRESENCE.
I DIDN'T FEEL THAT YOU EMBRACE--
OH MY GOD.
(gasping)
OH MY GOD, SOMEBODY CALL
THE AMBULANCE.
I'M CALLING 9-1-1,
I GOT IT.
♪♪♪
YOU LOOK REALLY PRETTY.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING,
YOU LOOK LIKE A SUPER MODEL.
(siren blaring)
YOU KNOW, I'M SURE THE GIRLS...
I JUST GOT NERVOUS
AND I HAD AN ANXIETY ATTACK.
FOR 19 YEARS, I'VE HAD
A CONDITION WHERE, YOU KNOW,
I PASS OUT FOR NO REASON,
ANYWHERE, ANYTIME.
DOESN'T MATTER.
BUT IF I'M NOT ELIMINATED
TONIGHT,
I WILL BE BACK TOMORROW,
STRONGER THAN EVER.
I'M NOT GONNA
LET THIS GET ME DOWN.
(sobbing)
Tyra: FEELING BETTER THAT NIGHT,
REBECCA WAS ABLE TO RETURN.
REBECCA.
YOU SCARED ALL OF US
SO MUCH TONIGHT, REBECCA.
I KNOW, I'M SO SORRY.
BUT I ADMIRE YOUR TENACITY
AND I ADMIRE YOU RETURNING.
THOUGH REBECCA RECOVERED
FROM HER FAINTING SPELL,
IN THE END,
SARAH COULDN'T RECOVER
FROM HER SHAKY WALK
AND STIFF PHOTO
SO MUCH HAS HAPPENED THIS CYCLE
THAT WE COULDN'T FIT
EVERYTHING IN.
HERE'S ANOTHER MOMENT
FROM "TOP MODEL" VAULT
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
WHOO!
I LOVE LADY KAT.
(meows)
(laughing)
all: ONE, TWO, THREE, REOW!
COMING UP, THE GIRLS BLOW OFF
SOME STEAM.
- RUN!
- GET HER!
AND BRITTANY GOES OVERBOARD.
♪♪♪
Tyra: SOMETIMES WHEN GIRLS COME
TO "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
THEY BRING BAGGAGE,
AND TIFFANY'S WAS HER TEMPER.
(screaming)
THAT STANK HO,
POURED THE BEER ON MY WEAVE.
Tyra: BUT AFTER TAKING
ANGER MANAGEMENT CLASSES,
SHE RETURNED
WITH A NEW ATTITUDE.
I DON'T JUMP ON PEOPLE
AND THROW GLASSES
AND STUFF LIKE THAT ANYMORE.
Tyra:
HAVING CHANGED HER ATTITUDE,
TIFFANY'S NEXT PROJECT
WAS BRANDY.
I CALLED WAY IN THE KITCHEN.
I SAID, AFTER NOELLE,
I WAS GONNA USE THE PHONE.
YOU WEREN'T OUT HERE, SWEETIE,
WE'VE ALL BEEN WAITING IN LINE.
I MEAN, IF Y'ALL WANNA GET RUDE
ABOUT IT, THEN WE CAN GET RUDE.
WE WERE LIKE, WHAT IS THIS?
YOU DO COME OFF LIKE A BITCH
SOMETIMES, YOU DO.
AND YOU GOTTA CHANGE THAT.
SO YOU GOTTA FIGURE OUT,
DO YOU WANNA BE A MODEL?
OKAY, SO YOU NEED
TO CHANGE YOUR ATTITUDE
'CAUSE YOUR ATTITUDE STINKS.
Tyra:
BUT SOMETIMES
THE OLD TIFFANY
WOULD TAKE CONTROL,
AND SHE'D LOSE IT.
THIS IS IT.
Tatiana: I WOULD GO OVER THERE
AND HELP HER BUT, LIKE,
THE SMELL OF VOMIT WILL MAKE ME
VOMIT MYSELF SO I'M LIKE,
OKAY, I DON'T WANNA BE THE OTHER
GIRL THAT VOMITS, RIGHT?
DON'T STEP IN IT,
DON'T STEP IN IT.
Tyra: TIFFANY WAS STILL
PAYING FOR THAT DINNER
THE NEXT MORNING.
I THINK I'M STILL DRUNK.
DRINK IT.
I'M NOT DRINKING THAT,
THAT'S HORRIBLE.
SISTER, YOU GOTTA DRINK IT.
Tyra: BUT TIFFANY'S DAY WAS
ABOUT TO GET EVEN TOUGHER.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
IN MODELING
IS DEALING WITH
DIFFICULT PERSONALITIES.
SO I ARRANGED FOR THE MODELS
TO MEET A TOUGH PHOTOGRAPHER.
I WAS INSTRUCTED TO PRETTY MUCH
TEAR THEM TO SHREDS.
LET'S DO IT!
OH!
I COULD BRING A MULE OVER HERE
AND IT'LL GIVE ME
A BETTER POSTURE AND BETTER
HITTING THE BALL, OKAY?
HIT THE MARK,
THE MARK IS THERE FOR A REASON.
AHH!
WITHOUT THE FAKE SMILE,
LOSE THE FAKE SMILE!
STOP, STOP WITH THE BALL,
STOP WITH THE BALL!
- HERE GOES NOTHING.
- Alex: I HOPE NOT.
Noelle:
I DON'T KNOW IF HE DIDN'T GET
HUGGED ENOUGH AS A CHILD,
I JUST KNOW THAT HE'S MEAN,
AND I DON'T LIKE HIM.
Alex: YOU CAN DO IT,
IT'S SIMPLE, IT IS.
I'M REALLY LIKE GOING TO
HAPPY PLACE,
HE'S FREAKING ME OUT.
NO.
Tyra: EVERY GIRL HANDLED
THE PRESSURE DIFFERENTLY.
TIFFANY BARELY KEPT HERSELF
IN CHECK.
Alex: WASTING MY TIME
AND EVERYBODY ELSE'S THEN.
Tiffany:
I WANT TO POUND HIS HEAD IN
WITH THAT TENNIS RACKET.
Alex: DON'T LOOK SCARED,
YOU'RE LOOKING SCARED.
Tyra: KAHLEN BROKE DOWN.
NOBODY HAS THE RIGHT TO TREAT
ANYONE LIKE THAT.
Tyra: NAIMA REMAINED CALM.
I HAD TO LAUGH AT THIS GUY.
Tyra: AND BRANDY,
SHE TOOK IT OUT ON TATIANA.
I WAS MAKING A JOKE TO MAKE
MYSELF LAUGH.
DON'T SAY NOTHING TO ME.
IF WE DIDN'T GET KICKED OFF
FOR HITTING SOMEBODY,
YOUR ASS WOULD BE
TORE UP RIGHT NOW,
'CAUSE I DIDN'T SAY -- TO YOU.
I REALLY DON'T SEE BRANDY
WORKING ON HER ATTITUDE
OR HER TACT RIGHT NOW,
WHICH IS SAD.
THE JUDGES
GAVE HER ANOTHER CHANCE,
AND I DON'T THINK
SHE'S USING THAT.
Tyra: HER ATTITUDE SPILLED OVER
INTO THE ZODIAC PHOTO SHOOT,
WHERE BRANDY COULDN'T
STOP COMPLAINING.
SO I'M LIKE THE LONGEST ONE,
HUH?
Jay: WELL, YEAH.
I'M ABOUT TO FALL.
Jay: NO, YOU'RE NOT,
YOU'RE NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
♪♪♪
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT
THE PHOTO AND THE FACE--
THERE'S SOMETHING
I'M NOT FEELING.
THERE'S NO PASSION IN THE EYES.
THE PHOTOGRAPHER THERE
WAS LIKE,
"OKAY, GIVE ME SEXY, OKAY,
WAIT A MINUTE, TOO SEXY.
MOVE TO THE LEFT,
MOVE TO THE RIGHT, SO..."
BRANDY, HAVE YOU HAD OTHER JOBS.
LIKE, HOW MANY OTHER JOBS
HAVE YOU HAD?
I THINK I HAD LIKE FOUR JOBS.
SO FOUR JOBS MEANS FOUR BOSSES.
AND FOUR BOSSES WITH FOUR
DIFFERENT TYPES OF STYLE
OF HOW THEY DEAL
WITH THEIR EMPLOYEES.
SAME WITH PHOTOGRAPHERS.
THERE'S DIFFERENT PERSONALITIES,
AND YOU HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO HANDLE ALL OF THEM
IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
IN THE END, THE JUDGES COULDN'T
GET PAST BRANDY'S ATTITUDE.
THANK YOU, BRANDY.
SO THEY SENT HER HOME.
BEING A TOP MODEL MEANS
BEING AWAY FROM YOUR FAMILY.
AND NOELLE HAD THE HARDEST TIME.
HEY, BABY BOY.
(baby talk on phone)
KISSY, KISSY, KISSY, MWAH.
IT'S REALLY LIKE AN
INDESCRIBABLE FEELING WHEN
YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE MISSING
LITERALLY A PART OF YOURSELF.
I KNOW SHE'S A PROUD MOTHER
BUT NOELLE TALKS CONSTANTLY
ABOUT HER CHILD 24/7.
MY BODY MATURED A LOT
FROM HAVING A BABY.
ONCE YOU HAVE A BABY...
MY SON WAS TAKING A NAP
FOR A GOOD HOUR AND A HALF.
THAT'S THE DAY AFTER
HE WAS BORN,
LOOK HOW PERFECT
HE LOOKS ALREADY.
I LOVE MY BABY, I MISS MY BABY,
I WANNA TALK TO MY BABY.
OH, YEAH.
OKAY, WE GOT IT,
YOU HAVE A KID, NEXT.
Tyra: WHEN MICHELLE WOKE UP WITH
OPEN SORES ALL OVER HER FACE,
NOELLE'S THOUGHTS TURNED
FROM HER BABY TO HER SAFETY.
THAT'S NOT A BUG BITE.
IT LOOKS LIKE SHE'S PUTTING OUT
CIGARETTES ON HER FACE.
I WANNA KNOW ABOUT IT
'CAUSE I DON'T WANT THAT
TO HAPPEN TO MY FACE.
THERE IS SOME STRAIN
OF BACTERIA
THAT IS RESISTANT
TO ANTIBIOTICS.
YOU CAN GET PNEUMONIA AND DIE
FROM THE PNEUMONIA.
OH!
IT HAS BEEN ALL OVER
THE MEDIA THAT THERE IS A NEW
FLESH-EATING BACTERIA THAT IS
UNCURABLE BY ANTIBIOTICS.
Tyra: AND AN ITCHING EPIDEMIC
EXPLODED.
WHAT!
WHOO, I'M ITCHY.
WE'RE ALL GONNA DIE!
Tyra: WHILE MICHELLE VISITED
A DERMATOLOGIST...
Man: HAVE YOU EVER
HEARD OF IMPETIGO?
NO.
IT'S USUALLY CAUSED BY BACTERIA
AND IT'S EASILY TREATABLE,
AND PROBABLY WILL GO AWAY
FAIRLY QUICKLY.
THANK YOU, I APPRECIATE IT.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
Tyra: THE GIRLS FACED
A COMPLEX PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE THEY HAD TO PORTRAY
DIFFERENT ETHNICITIES
WHILE JUGGLING A GLASS OF MILK
AND A HEAVY TODDLER.
HE'S SLIDING.
- I'M JUST SLIPPING DOWN.
- YOU ARE SLIPPING, HUH?
Man: DON'T PULL OUT HER HAT.
DO YOU HAVE GUM?
NO, I DON'T HAVE ANY GUM,
SWEETIE.
HIGH FIVE, ALL RIGHT.
Tyra: MICHELLE RETURNED
WITH THE DOCTOR'S APPROVAL.
IT'LL CLEAR UP, IT'S CONTAGIOUS.
Tyra: BUT SHE WASN'T ALLOWED
TO POSE WITH A TODDLER.
YOU NEED TO BOND
WITH YOUR CHILD.
HE'S NOT GONNA BEHAVE
LIKE THE REST OF 'EM.
Tyra: AND SOME OF THE GIRLS
THOUGHT THIS WAS UNFAIR.
OKAY, WILL SHE BEAT US
AT THIS CHALLENGE?
NO, WE DON'T, WE WANNA GO PUT
SOME WEIGHTS IN THE THING.
IT'S NOT A SORORITY.
THIS IS A MODELING COMPETITION.
♪♪♪
IT WAS LIGHT.
SHE COMES OUT OF THE SHOOT
AND SAYS,
"WHOO, YEAH, I ONLY HAD
A HALF-POUND BABY."
I WANT TO TAKE THAT DARK WIG OFF
MICHELLE'S HEAD AND SAY,
"YOU'RE RIGHT, YOU ONLY HAD
A HALF-POUND BABY BECAUSE
"YOU SCRATCHED YOUR FACE,
YOU GOT BACTERIA ON YOUR FACE
AND NOW YOU'RE NOT CAPABLE."
Tyra: BUT IN THE END IT WAS
NOELLE WHO DIDN'T MEASURE UP.
NOELLE, THE JUDGES SEE YOU
AND THEY SAY,
"SHE DOESN'T REALLY LOOK
LIKE A MODEL IN PERSON."
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
Noelle:
THE PERSON I PERSONALLY THINK
SHOULD'VE GONE HOME
WAS MICHELLE.
THAT SOFT, SILENT, SWEET LITTLE
ATTITUDE THAT YOU PUT ON
FOR THE JUDGES,
ISN'T REALLY WHO YOU ARE.
AND SOONER OR LATER,
THAT'LL COME OUT.
Tyra: THE PRESSURE OF
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
AFFECTS EACH GIRL
IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
SOME GIRLS TURN SILLY...
OH, YOU ASS.
SHUT THE DOOR!
SHUT THE DOOR.
THERE'S NOWHERE TO HIDE,
THERE'S NOWHERE TO HIDE!
I DON'T KNOW!
GET HER!
- ALL RIGHT, TRUCE?
- TRUCE.
Tyra: SOME GIRLS SHUT DOWN.
(crickets chirping)
(owl hooting)
AND SOME HANDLE THE STRESS
BY GOING WILD.
AND WILD...
AND WILD.
I THINK THAT I AM DEFINITELY
THE ENTERTAINMENT.
WHAT ARE THEY GONNA DO
WITHOUT ME IF I LEAVE?
WHOO! WHOA.
THERE'S NEVER A DULL MOMENT
WITH THAT GIRL.
RIGHT HERE, GO FOR IT.
THERE YOU GO.
♪♪♪
PUT YOUR FEET THIS WAY.
PUT YOUR HEAD BACK THIS WAY,
COME HERE.
RIGHT THERE.
IF ANYTHING, BRITTANY IS HAVING
A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH FUN.
Tyra: AT A COVER GIRL PARTY,
THE GIRLS WORKED TO IMPRESS
INDUSTRY INSIDERS.
IT FEELS LIKE I'M DREAMING AND
I'M GONNA WAKE UP ANY DAY NOW?
Tyra: WHILE THE OTHER GIRLS
WORKED THE ROOM,
BRITTANY WAS BUSY
WORKING ON A BUZZ.
HOLD ON, DRINKS!
BRITTANY, SHE WANTED A DRINK
AND SHE WAS GONNA HAVE A DRINK
AND THAT WAS ALL.
BRITTANY,
THEY WERE A LITTLE CONCERNED.
THEY THOUGHT YOUR PRIORITY WAS
MORE ABOUT YOUR DRINKING
THAN MEETING EVERYBODY
AT THE PARTY.
NO ONE WANTS TO HEAR
NEGATIVE FEEDBACK, IT'S HURTFUL.
IT'S VERY NERVE-WRACKING.
Tyra: FEELING OVERWHELMED,
BRITTANY TURNED TO HER ROOMMATE
KEENYAH AND FOUND A FRIEND.
I REALLY THINK YOU'RE SPECIAL.
IF I'M IN A ROOM AND YOU'RE
NOT AROUND, IT'S LIKE...
WHERE'S BRITTANY?
YOU HAVE PRESENCE,
I FEEL LIKE THE ROOM IS FULL.
IT CAN BE JUST ME AND YOU,
AND IT WILL FEEL LIKE
EVERYBODY HERE.
THANK YOU A LOT.
I JUST CAN'T--
HOW MUCH I LOVE YOU!
OH.
Tyra: AT THE NEXT PHOTO SHOOT,
THE GIRLS HAD TO BRAVE
THE ELEMENTS.
♪♪♪
A DETERMINED BRITTANY,
BLEW JAY AWAY.
Jay: SHE WAS VERY REMINISCENT
OF THE EARLY JANICE DICKINSON.
SHE LOOKED GREAT.
PULL UP!
LLUVY, BE GRACEFUL.
SMILE, SMILE, LAUGH!
BUT LLUVY BRING HIM
CRASHING DOWN TO EARTH.
OH, SHE LOOKS LIKE A DRAG QUEEN.
YOU NEVER PLAYED SEXY
IN THE SHOWER, DID YOU?
NEVER, EVER, EVER.
GO HOME, PLAY SEXY
IN THE SHOWER.
YOU HAVE THE WATER ON,
AND YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE THE HOTTEST THING
SINCE SLICED BREAD.
YOU'RE A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
YOU NEED TO START
REALIZING THAT.
Tyra: LLUVY HAD A UNIQUE BEAUTY,
BUT SHE DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO PUT
THAT ON A PICTURE.
SO IT WAS HER TURN TO GO HOME.
Janice: TAKE CARE, DOLL.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
Tyra: HERE'S ANOTHER MOMENT
FROM THE "TOP MODEL" VAULT.
YOU HAVE TO SELL YOUR PRODUCT
TO US.
IT'S GOT A FRUITY SMELL,
AND, UM...
IT'S...
TATIANA.
I...
(chuckling)
REALLY, UM...
JUST HERE,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
THANK YOU.
'CAUSE YOU DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT TO SAY.
COMING UP,
TIFFANY TRIES SOMETHING NEW.
SUSHI!
AND SOME SPECIAL GUESTS
SURPRISE THE GIRLS.
MY MOM IS HERE.
WIND HER UP
AND WIND HER UP TIGHT.
♪♪♪
Tyra: BEING A TOP MODEL, MEANS
MANAGING MANY NEW EXPERIENCES.
SOME GIRLS DEAL WITH THIS
BETTER THAN OTHERS.
SUSHI!
I'M NOT USED
TO EATING RAW STUFF.
I'M USED TO HAVING IT COOKED
OR BURNT OR SOMETHING.
HERE, TRY THAT ONE.
TRY THAT, TRY THAT.
TRY THIS WITHOUT THE SKIN,
JUST TRY IT.
TIFFANY, SHE DOESN'T EAT A LOT
WHEN WE GOT OUT BECAUSE
SHE'S JUST LIKE REALLY
NOT USED TO THE FOOD,
AND SHE REALLY DOESN'T LIKE IT.
THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE IS TOTALLY
DIFFERENT FROM ANYTHING
I'VE EVER BEEN IN MY WHOLE LIFE.
AND IT FEELS LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE
IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMFORTABLE THAN ME.
Tyra: AS IF EATING FOREIGN FOOD
WASN'T ENOUGH,
NEXT TIFFANY HAD TO LEARN
A FOREIGN WAY OF SPEAKING.
AS MODELS, YOU'LL BE CALLED
ON TO HAVE A LOT
IN YOUR BAG OF TRICKS.
I'M GOING TO TEACH YOU
A DIALECT: COCKNEY.
COCKNEY?
I CAN BARELY SPEAK ENGLISH.
Tyra: TO TOP IT OFF,
SHE HAD TO USE THE ACCENT
IN A SCENE WITH SEXY ACTOR
BORIS KODJOE.
WHAT?!
OH NO!
IT'S NOT ONE OF THOSE SCENES
WHERE I COULD BE CUTE
AROUND BORIS.
I HAVE TO HAVE
A DAMN MISSING TOOTH
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF MY MOUTH.
(laughing)
WELL, HELLO THERE, GOVERNOR.
- LOVELY DAY, ISN'T IT?
- I HAVEN'T NOTICED.
WELL, THE SUN'S SHINNING.
THE SKY'S SPARKLING BLUE.
I CAN'T REMEMBER NO STUPIDNESS
LIKE ENGLISH COCKNEY?
I'M REALLY EMBARRASSED.
MAYBE I CAN'T BE THIS PERSON
THAT-- THIS MODEL GIRL THAN
MAYBE THAT'S NOT WHO I AM.
Tyra: FRUSTRATED BY
THE COMPETITION,
TIFFANY CALLED HER GRANDMOTHER
TO VENT.
I CAN'T TAKE SOMEBODY
LOOKING DOWN ON ME,
TRYING TO MAKE ME FEEL
LIKE I'M LESS OF MYSELF.
SO I REALIZED, I'MA BE THE BEST
TIFFANY I CAN BE.
THEY EITHER LOVE IT OR DON'T.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
YOU AIN'T NO QUITTER,
YOU ARE A FIGHTER.
I'M NOT GONNA QUIT.
Tyra:
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT,
IT WAS REBECCA'S TURN
TO STRUGGLE.
YES.
Rebecca:
OH, JEEZ, I'M NOT EXCITED
LIKE SOME OF THE GIRLS HERE.
I'M ENGAGED AND ABOUT TO BE
MARRIED WHEN I GET HOME
SO IT'S A LITTLE AWKWARD.
OKAY, NOW THE ESTROGEN'S
REALLY FLOWING.
WE'RE HORNY.
CAN I BE FIRST? RIGHT HERE,
RIGHT HERE, I'M READY.
WORK IT OUT!
OH, GOOD GIRL!
BRITTANY, ACT OUT!
HOLD THAT PILLOW, GIRL,
HOLD THAT PILLOW.
DON'T BE AFRAID OF HIM.
WHOO!
- COME ON, LAUGH AT HIM.
- COME ON, TIFFANY.
I SEE THIS IS MY TEST.
IF I CAN PULL THIS OFF,
THEN GREAT,
I HOPE I'LL GET TO STICK AROUND.
BUT I'M--
I'M REALLY TERRIFIED.
- HIT HIM!
- LOOK AT HIM!
THERE YOU GO!
I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE A PICTURE
THE JUDGES ARE GONNA
BE HAPPY WITH.
I'VE NEVER WALKED AWAY
FROM ANY PHOTO SHOOT
GOING, "YES, I NAILED IT."
I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK WE ALL GOT HAIR BALLED.
Tyra: FOR THE JUDGING CHALLENGE,
THE GIRLS HAD TO PUT
THEIR NEW ACTING SKILLS
TO THE TEST
AND BECOME CORRESPONDENTS.
EVERY GIRL STRUGGLED.
HI, MICHELLE HERE.
IT'S FASHION WEEK IN PARIS.
CAN YOU SAY...
- "MAGNETA?"
- MA-GEN-TA?
"IZZY MI-E?"
"ICY ME-AKE."
LOOKS TO THE LEFT, WHOA.
"AU REVOIR."
Tyra: AND ONCE AGAIN,
TIFFANY GAVE UP ON HERSELF.
I CAN'T DO THIS.
TIFFANY, THE OTHER GIRLS
DID NOT KNOW THESE WORDS.
JUST HAVE FUN WITH IT,
USE YOUR PERSONALITY, BE YOU.
WHILE THE JUDGES DELIBERATED,
TIFFANY SHARED HER FRUSTRATION
WITH THE OTHER GIRLS.
I QUIT THE WHOLE THING.
- OH, HOW DID IT GO?
- HORRIBLE.
A PART OF ME KIND OF GAVE UP
ON THE INSIDE.
SO I WASN'T BEING
THE BEST TIFFANY I CAN BE.
EVERY WEEK,
I DO SOMETHING STUPID,
I MESS UP WITH SOMETHING.
THEY MAKING IT LIKE,
MAKING ME HATE THIS.
DON'T WANNA SEEM LIKE
I'M UNGRATEFUL FOR BEING HERE.
I LOVE BEING HERE,
BUT I WAS TIRED OF IT.
I FEEL LIKE TODAY, I WANNA GO.
TIFFANY WAS READY TO GO.
BUT REBECCA WAS ABOUT TO HEAR
SOME HARD NEWS.
BOTH OF YOU WILL PACK YOUR BAGS
AND RETURN TO THE LOFT.
BUT WHEN TIFFANY LAUGHED OFF
HER ELIMINATION,
I GOT FRUSTRATED
WITH HER ATTITUDE.
TIFFANY, I'M EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTED IN YOU.
THIS IS A JOKE TO YOU.
I'M HURT, BUT EVERY TIME
I COME HERE,
IT'S, "OH, YOU HAVE
A BAD ATTITUDE."
I DON'T HAVE A BAD ATTITUDE.
MAYBE I AM ANGRY INSIDE.
I'VE BEEN THROUGH STUFF
SO I'M ANGRY.
YES, BUT DOES NOT--
THIS IS NOT-- BE QUIET, TIFFANY.
BE QUIET!
THAT IS WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU.
STOP IT!
I HAVE NEVER IN MY LIFE
YELLED AT A GIRL LIKE THIS!
I WAS ROOTING FOR YOU.
LEARN SOMETHING FROM THIS!
WHEN YOU GO TO BED AT NIGHT,
YOU LAY THERE AND YOU TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR YOURSELF,
BECAUSE NOBODY'S GOING TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR YOU.
YOU'RE ROLLING YOUR EYES
AND YOU ACT LIKE IT'S BECAUSE
YOU'VE HEARD IT ALL BEFORE.
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR YOURSELF.
ANYBODY ELSE'LL TELL ME
TO SHUT UP,
I WOULD'VE SLAPPED THEM.
BUT SHE WAS RIGHT 'CAUSE
SHE COULD'VE EASILY SAID,
"OKAY, WHATEVER, YOU KNOW, BYE."
THAT SHOWED ME THAT SHE SAW
DEEPLY INTO ME.
SHE CARED ABOUT ME
AND THAT'S COOL KNOWING THAT,
YOU KNOW,
TYRA CARES ABOUT YOU.
I HAVE THE UTMOST
RESPECT FOR HER.
I'M GONNA GO BACK HOME
AND HAVE A GOOD LIFE NOW
AND BE THE BEST TIFFANY
I CAN BE.
Rebecca: I'M REALLY
DISAPPOINTED RIGHT NOW.
BUT I'M GOING HOME
TO GET MARRIED.
AND WE'LL TAKE IT FROM THERE.
♪♪♪
Tatiana: WHEN TYRA WAS YELLING
AT TIFFANY,
I UNDERSTOOD, LIKE,
WHERE SHE WAS COMING FROM
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, TYRA IS
REALLY PASSIONATE.
SO TODAY,
WE'RE KIND OF FEELING LIKE,
WOW, WE NEED TO MOVE IT UP
A LITTLE BIT.
OH, BABY.
Tyra: THE NEXT DAY, THE GIRLS
GOT A LESSON IN INTERVIEWING
FROM "ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT'S"
JANN CARL.
I AM HERE TODAY
TO TEACH YOU HOW TO ACT
WHEN YOU ARE THROWN INTO
THE MEDIA SPOTLIGHT.
Tyra: CHRISTINA AND TATIANA
LEARNED THAT THEY NEEDED
TO EXPAND THEIR VOCABULARY.
HI, I'M CHRISTINA WITH
"ENTERTAINMENT TONIGHT."
AND WE ARE ACTUALLY HERE
WITH "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL",
TATIANA.
ACTUALLY,
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
UM, ACTUALLY, I WAS WONDERING,
HAS THERE BEEN ANY DESIGNERS
OR ANY MODELS THAT HAVE INSPIRED
YOU OR ANY FAMILY MEMBERS?
ACTUALLY, UM, MY COUSIN.
HE'S ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW,
ALWAYS PUSHED ME AND PUSHED ME
AND MYSELF,
I PUSH MYSELF A LOT, ACTUALLY.
Christina:
IT'S A LOT MORE DIFFICULT
THAN YOU ACTUALLY THINK IT IS.
SO I'M GLAD WE HAD
THE EXPERIENCE, ACTUALLY.
Tyra: CHRISTINA AND TATIANA
TANKED AT THE LESSON,
BUT MADE A MAJOR COMEBACK
AT THE CHALLENGE
WITH RAPPER,
ACTRESS, DESIGNER, EVE.
WHERE DID YOU GET
THE NAME "FETISH" FROM?
WHERE DID YOU COME UP WITH THAT?
AND IF YOU COULD SUM UP YOUR
LINE AS FAR AS ATTITUDE-WISE
IN ONE WORD,
WHAT WOULD IT BE?
HMM... THAT'S HARD.
HELLO AGAIN.
Tyra: TATIANA THOUGHT THAT SHE
HAD THE COMPETITION IN THE BAG.
BUT THE WINNER OF THE CHALLENGE
IS CHRISTINA.
OH, THANK YOU.
Tatiana: I THOUGHT I DID
A REALLY GOOD JOB.
AND SO I'M JUST LIKE
KIND OF BUMMED A LITTLE BIT.
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE
THAT COMES WITH WINNING
THIS CHALLENGE,
BUT YOU HAVE TO PICK A FRIEND
TO ENJOY IT WITH.
BRITTANY.
YEAH!
Tyra: THEIR PRIZE WAS A VISIT
FROM SOME SPECIAL GUESTS.
BRITTANY!
- (screaming)
- OH MY-- OH MY GOD!
I CAN'T BELIEVE MY MOM IS HERE.
- (screaming)
- MY MOM!
I WAS LIKE, WHERE'S MY MOM?
AND THEN I REMEMBERED,
BRITTANY AND CHRISTINA WON
THE CHALLENGE, SO...
ONLY THEIR MOMMIES ARE HERE.
WE CAN PRETEND
WE'RE YOU'RE MAMAS.
OHH...
THEY LOOKED LIKE THEIR MOMS.
THE BIG EYES,
YOU SEE THAT LITTLE LIPS.
THERE'S NO TOP LIP THERE.
THEY ACT AND TALK
LIKE THEIR MOMS.
WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN DOING
TILL YOU CAME HERE?
YOUR MOM WAS DANCING
WITH SIX BIKERS.
BRITTANY'S MOM HAS A SENSE
OF HUMOR JUST LIKE BRITTANY.
OH, YEAH.
THEN YOU WIND HER UP
AND WIND HER UP TIGHT.
DINNER'S READY!
Tyra: HAVING BRITTANY
AND CHRISTINA'S MOMS AROUND
MADE KAHLEN MISS HER FAMILY.
BUT CALLS HOME
DIDN'T ALWAYS END HAPPILY.
DAMMIT!
I CHECKED MY MESSAGES
AND ONE OF MY FRIENDS
FROM HIGH SCHOOL
HAD, UM, HAD PASSED AWAY.
I DON'T KNOW
IF I CAN HANDLE THIS.
Tyra: IN A CHILLING COINCIDENCE,
THAT WEEK'S PHOTO SHOOT
TOOK PLACE IN A CEMETERY.
YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA HAVE
TO PORTRAY
ONE OF THESE SEVEN DEADLY SINS
AT THE BOTTOM
OF THIS EIGHT-FOOT GRAVE.
Tyra: KAHLEN TRIED TO KEEP HER
EMOTIONS IN CHECK.
BUT HAVING TO POSE
IN AN OPEN GRAVE
PUSHED HER OVER THE EDGE.
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND.
(sobbing)
Tyra: KAHLEN WAS ABLE TO USE
HER RAGE TO EMBODY
THE DEADLY SIN OF WRATH
AND PUT IT IN HER PHOTOGRAPH.
YEAH, THAT'S GREAT,
JUST KEEP IT RIGHT THERE.
NICE.
GIVE ME, GRR.
(growling)
OKAY, ONE MORE.
Tyra: IN THE END,
KAHLEN PUSHED THROUGH HER GRIEF
FOR A STUNNING PHOTOGRAPH.
BUT TATIANA
COULDN'T MAKE THE GRADE.
TATIANA ON A GLOBAL LEVEL,
EVEN FOR THE UNITED STATES,
IS NOT TOP MODEL.
SHE JUST ISN'T.
Tyra: SO WE SENT HER HOME.
Tatiana: I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED
IN MYSELF.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I JUST--
MAYBE IT WASN'T
THE RIGHT PATH FOR ME.
Tyra: AND NOW
SOME MORE MODEL MOMENTS
FROM THE "TOP MODEL" VAULT.
SO NOW, OF COURSE,
YOU GUYS KNOW,
WE HAVE A CRAZY PANEL OF JUDGES
STARTING WITH...
WHY AM I THE CRAZY?
I DON'T KNOW WHY
YOU'RE CRAZY, JANICE.
I'M GONNA COME OVER THERE
AND STRANGLE YOU.
- ALL RIGHTY.
- CAN WE BOOT TWO TONIGHT?
I LOVE YOU, JANICE.
WELL, WAIT A MINUTE,
I'M ASKING--
- OH, SHUT UP, JANICE.
- SHUT UP.
SHUT UP, JANICE.
- YOU BETTER THAN SHUT ME UP.
- THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE.
THE LOVELY SANE...
JANICE DICKINSON.
COMING UP NEXT, IT'S NIGHT
OF PASSION IN THE JUDGING ROOM.
(screaming)
AND IN THE HOUSE.
Tyra: HIGH FASHION
HAPPENS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
SO I HAD THE GIRLS
PACK THEIR BAGS
TO HEAD FOR SOUTH AFRICA.
GOODBYE, L.A.
Tyra: THE GIRLS WERE EXCITED
TO BEING THEIR SOUTH AFRICAN
ADVENTURE.
- CHEERS.
- TO AFRICA.
Tyra: BUT MICHELLE FELT
AS ALONE ON THE PLANE
AS SHE OFTEN FELT IN THE HOUSE.
Michelle: I THINK THE GIRLS
PERCEIVE ME AS A LONER.
AND I'VE BEEN TRYING
TO CONNECT WITH THEM MORE.
ONCE AGAIN, EVERYONE'S LEAVING
ME HERE BY MYSELF.
I THINK I HAVE A WAYS TO GO.
(men singing)
Tyra: WHEN THE GIRLS
GOT TO SOUTH AFRICA,
A DETERMINED MICHELLE
TRIED TO RELATE.
DID YOU READ THE PACKET?
IT SAID WHEN YOU'RE IN
A CONVERSATION,
DON'T PUT YOUR HANDS IN YOUR
POCKET 'CAUSE THAT'S RUDE
AND DON'T POINT
WITH YOUR INDEX FINGER.
REALLY?
WELL, THAT'S THE SAME RULE
AS IN AMERICA.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT
IN AMERICA, EITHER.
AFTER GOING ON SAFARI TONIGHT,
THE GIRLS HAD SOME QUIET TIME
TO REFLECT.
Michelle: I'VE LEARNED MORE
IN THIS PAST MONTH FROM YOU GUYS
THAN I THINK I HAVE IN SCHOOL
OR, YOU KNOW, ANYTHING.
'CAUSE THIS EXPERIENCE
JUST KINDA THROWS EVERYTHING
AT YOU AT ONCE.
OH, YEAH, SINCE, LIKE WHEN
WE VERY FIRST STARTED THIS,
I WAS... A LITTLE MORE TIMID,
SHY, SORT OF.
THIS EXPERIENCE KIND OF LIKE
MAKES YOU CONFRONT WHO YOU ARE.
OH, YEAH.
NOT THE PERSON THAT YOU PRETEND
TO BE ON THE OUTSIDE.
IT MAKES YOU DEAL WITH
THE PERSON THAT YOU ARE INSIDE.
Kahlen: I THINK MICHELLE'S
MADE THE MOST PROGRESS
OUT OF ANY OF US.
YOU KNOW, PICTURE AFTER PICTURE,
YOU'RE AMAZED.
YOU'RE LIKE,
MICHELLE, IS THAT YOU?
THE ONLY THING THAT MICHELLE
NEEDS NOW IS TO LEARN
HOW TO JUST RELAX
AND LET SOME OF THOSE NERVES OUT
AND SOME OF THE TENSION OUT.
Tyra: KEENYAH HAD CONCERNS
OF HER OWN.
LIKE HER RECENT WEIGHT GAIN.
KEENYAH CAN SNACK LIKE NO OTHER.
SHE HAS GAINED
ABOUT TEN POUNDS.
SO YOU THINK TOMORROW,
IF I DON'T EAT--
NO, DON'T EVER NOT EAT.
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN
GAINING WEIGHT,
YOU JUST HAVEN'T
BEEN WATCHING WHAT YOU EAT.
JUNK FOOD, WHICH HAS TONS
OF SODIUM,
YOU'RE RETAINING TONS OF WATER.
Tyra: AT THE PHOTO SHOOT
LATER THAT DAY,
KEENYAH HAD TO PORTRAY
AN ELEPHANT
WITH A REVEALING COSTUME.
Keenyah: THE STOMACH IS EXPOSED,
IT'S BLOATED.
I HAVE TO JUST TRY
TO SUCK IT IN AND WORK IT.
Tyra: FOR THE JUDGING CHALLENGE,
THE GIRLS HAD TO POSE
WITH AN OBJECT
WHILE DISPLAYING AN EMOTION.
NAIMA ALMOST NAILED IT.
MICHELLE LOOKED NERVOUS.
MICHELLE, YOU LOOKED
QUITE SCARED THE WHOLE TIME.
KAHLEN AND CHRISTINA
LACKED PASSION.
SO JANICE DECIDED TO SHOW THEM
HOW IT'S DONE.
(screaming/laughing)
- WAIT, WAIT!
- JANICE!
PERHAPS I CAN GET INVOLVED.
THAT'S JUST GIRLS HAVING FUN.
THAT'S PASSION.
DURING EVALUATIONS, KEENYAH'S
PICTURE WAS A BIG PROBLEM.
THIS PHOTO IS REALLY BEAUTIFUL,
KEENYAH, BUT I HATE TO SAY IT,
THEY HAD TO DO A LOT OF BODY
WORK ON YOU IN RE-TOUCHING.
I THINK IT'S
ALL ABOUT CHOICES, KEENYAH.
YOU CAN GET A BURGER
AND TAKE THE BREAD OFF.
BUT IN THE END, THIS COMPETITION
PROVED TOO MUCH FOR MICHELLE.
MICHELLE,
BEING A TOP MODEL MEANS
BEING UNDER PRESSURE CONSTANTLY.
WE'RE NOT SURE IF YOU'RE
STRONG ENOUGH FOR THAT.
SO WE HAD TO SEND HER HOME.
BACK AT THE HOTEL,
NAIMA AND CHRISTINA PLOTTED
TO PUT A LITTLE PASSION
INTO KAHLEN'S CONFESSIONAL.
I'M BECOMING MORE COMFORTABLE...
WITH MY OWN, YOU KNOW,
UNDER MY SKIN.
I AM STILL NAIVE TO THIS WORLD.
I'M STILL ON THE ROAD
TO FINDING OUT WHO I TRULY AM.
- (door opens)
- KAHLEN!
DO YOU WANNA SEE PASSION?
- I WANT PASSION.
- COME ON, SHOW HER PASSION.
(shrieking)
TELL YOUR LOVE
I'M GOING TO SEE YOU.
(Naima screaming)
(laughing)
YOU WANT ME TO TAKE THAT,
YOU WANT ME TO TALK THAT?
- GOT IT.
- THERE YOU GO, PASSION!
(laughing)
I FELT TONGUE AROUND THAT GRAPE.
YUP.
(laughing)
SOMETIMES CHRISTINA
IS VERY SERIOUS.
LIKE, SOMETIMES I REALLY SEE
CHRISTINA JUST--
HAVE FUN AND JUST LIKE
JOKE AROUND AND PLAY.
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR HER TO BRING
THAT PERSON WITH HER TO PANEL.
Tyra: WHEN I DROPPED BY
FOR DINNER,
CHRISTINA'S COLDNESS
WAS THE TOPIC OF DISCUSSION.
LIKE WHEN I'M WITH THESE GIRLS,
LIKE,
I'M SO HAPPY AND SO WARM
AND SO FUNNY AND STUFF.
BUT WHEN I GET IN THAT ROOM,
I FEEL LIKE, FOR SOME REASON,
I HOLD BACK
WHEN IT COMES TO PANEL.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S NERVES,
INTIMIDATION, WHAT IT IS,
BUT IT'S LIKE, I SEE MYSELF
AS A TOTALLY DIFFERENT PERSON
EVERY TIME I'M IN THAT ROOM.
YOU HAVE TO JUST PRETEND WE'RE
SITTING THERE IN OUR UNDERWEAR.
YOU IN YOUR UNDERWEAR
IS GONNA BE BEAUTIFUL
SO THAT'S NOT GONNA HELP.
Tyra: THE NEXT DAY,
THE GIRLS WENT ON GO-SEES
WITH THE TOP PEOPLE
IN THE SOUTH AFRICAN
FASHION INDUSTRY.
Christina: I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS
TO GO IN THERE
AND HAVE TO SELL YOURSELF
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE THING,
I'M HONESTLY,
NOT REALLY GOOD AT.
Tyra: ONCE AGAIN, CHRISTINA
HAD TROUBLE WARMING UP.
(cricket chirping)
KAHLEN HAD TROUBLE BEING EDGY.
IF YOU LOOK AT YOUR PICTURES,
IT LOOKS VERY INNOCENT.
I THINK AT THE MOMENT,
IN SOUTH AFRICA,
WE DEFINITELY
GOT MORE EDGE TO IT.
Tyra: BUT KEENYAH HAD NO TROUBLE
AT ALL BEING COMPETITIVE.
Keenyah: NAIMA WAS THERE FIRST,
I CAME SECOND.
MAYBE I SHOULD JUST WAIT
BUT IT'S A COMPETITION.
HI, I'M KEENYAH.
Tyra: LITERALLY PUSHING
HER COMPETITORS OUT OF THE WAY.
KEENYAH'S VERY COMPETITIVE,
THAT'S JUST HOW SHE IS.
AND I THINK SHE FEELS THAT
SHE HAS TO STEP IT UP EVEN MORE
TO MAKE UP FOR HER WEIGHT.
Tyra: AT THE PHOTO SHOOT,
KAHLEN STILL STRUGGLED.
DO YOU FEEL SEXY TODAY?
I DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
Tyra: AND KEENYAH WAS QUICK
TO POINT OUT KAHLEN'S FAULTS.
Keenyah: ONE THING THAT I GUESS
YOU WERE CHALLENGED WITH TODAY
WHICH WAS YOUR INNOCENCE AGAIN.
REMEMBER OUR GO-SEE THINGS,
THEY SAID, LOTS OF INNOCENCE.
INNOCENCE, INNOCENCE.
Kahlen: YEAH, THAT WAS
JUST ONE GIRL, THOUGH.
WITH KEENYAH, I FEEL LIKE SHE
HAS TO CUT OTHER PEOPLE DOWN
TO MAKE HERSELF FEEL BETTER
ABOUT HERSELF.
AS THE WEEKS GO ON, I JUST--
I CAN'T TAKE IT.
Tyra: AND ALTHOUGH,
CHRISTINA BARED HER BODY,
SHE HAD A HARD TIME
BARING HER SOUL.
IF YOU WALKED IN MY DOORS,
I DON'T KNOW HOW I'D SELL YOU
BECAUSE I'M NOT FEELING
ANYTHING FROM YOU.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE
CONFIDENCE MEETS COLD.
WHAT WE WANNA SEE IS FIRE
COMING FROM WITHIN,
AND YOU'RE NOT
GETTING IT AT ALL.
Tyra: SO SHE WAS SENT HOME.
I KNOW I'M NOT THIS COLD...
LIKE, RESERVED PERSON.
I JUST DON'T KNOW-- I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED TO ME.
Tyra: BEING IN SOUTH AFRICA
MADE KEENYAH PROUD TO GET
IN TOUCH WITH HER ROOTS.
IT'S GOOD TO COME HERE,
NOT THAT IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
TO ME THAN THEM
'CAUSE THEY'RE NOT BLACK.
I'M BLACK.
I'M BLACK AND I DO FEEL LIKE
THIS IS MY HOME.
THIS IS WHERE MY ROOTS ARE.
TO ME, BEING BLACK,
I WAS LIKE, THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I HAVE TO DO BEFORE I DIE,
I HAVE TO GO TO AFRICA.
I'VE HEARD HER SAY IT
SO MANY TIMES, THIS JUST MEANS
SO MUCH TO ME 'CAUSE I'M BLACK
AND IT'S JUST LIKE,
OKAY, ALL RIGHT, GREAT.
I KNOW THIS EXPERIENCE MEANS
A LOT TO NAIMA AS WELL.
Tyra: THE TENSION GREW ON A TRIP
TO NELSON MANDELA'S
FORMER PRISON CELL.
ONE OF YOU LADIES WILL HAVE
THE PLEASURE TO OPEN
MR. MANDELA'S CELL.
KEENYAH WANTED TO UNLOCK IT.
SHE THINKS JUST BECAUSE
SHE'S THE BLACK ONE
THAT SHE DESERVES TO OPEN IT.
I DON'T REALLY THINK
OF NAIMA AS BLACK.
I JUST DON'T SEE THAT IN HER.
MY FATHER IS BLACK
AND MEXICO-INDIAN.
MY MAMA IS BLACK AND IRISH.
I'M NOT THE TYPICAL BLACK GIRL
BUT IT MEANS A LOT
FOR ME BEING HERE.
1964 TO 1982.
THAT'S THE COURAGE
OF THAT ONE MAN KEPT US GOING.
I DIDN'T EVEN THINK THAT KEENYAH
KNEW WHO HE WAS.
SHE DOESN'T KNOW
IF HE'S ALIVE OR NOT.
SO I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY
SHE WAS GETTING SO EMOTIONAL.
Tyra: AND LATER
THE TENSION EXPLODED.
WHEN HE GAVE HER THE KEY,
YOU CRIED ABOUT IT.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
IF HE WAS STILL ALIVE OR NOT.
IT WAS AN EMOTIONAL
MOMENT FOR ME.
YOU WERE NOT IN MY SHOES,
YOU DON'T KNOW
HOW I FELT AT THAT MOMENT.
YOU ARE JUST SAYING THIS
'CAUSE YOU'RE BLACK,
YOU'VE SAID IT A MILLION TIMES.
WHAT YOU THINK?
YEAH, 'CAUSE I'M BLACK!
OH MY GOD!
SHUT UP!
Tyra: THE FIGHTING TOOK
ITS TOLL ON BRITTANY
AND SHE WASN'T HERSELF
DURING JUDGING.
PERSONALITY'S JUST NOT THERE.
WHERE'S MY BRITTANY.
MY GIRL NEED TO REALLY SPICE IT
UP A LITTLE BIT MORE.
Tyra: SO WE DECIDED
TO SEND HER HOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IT'S JUST HARD
WHEN YOU'RE SO CLOSE AND YET...
...SO FAR.
Tyra: NOW IT'S DOWN
TO THE FINAL THREE.
KEENYAH, THE SUPER CONFIDENT
COMPTON BEAUTY
WITH A COMPETITIVE EDGE.
NAIMA, THE MOHAWK DANCER
FROM DETROIT
STRUGGLING TO MAKE
HER PERSONALITY POP.
AND KAHLEN,
THE SHY OKLAHOMA GIRL
STRIVING TO SHED HER INSECURITY.
WHO WILL BE
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"?
TUNE IN TOMORROW NIGHT
TO FIND OUT.
♪ NAH-NAH-NAH-NAH-NAH ♪♪
STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM THE SEASON FINALE
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL".
TOMORROW ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL".
KAHLEN, NAIMA AND KEENYAH
HAVE ALMOST MADE IT TO THE TOP.
BUT FIRST,
THEY HAVE TO BATTLE IT OUT
IN A COVER GIRL
COMMERCIAL SHOOT.
ENERGY, PLEASE!
Tyra: AND IN
A CAPE TOWN RUNWAY SHOW.
IT ALL LEADS UP
TO THE FINAL DECISION.
WHO WILL BE
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"?
FIND OUT TOMORROW NIGHT.
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA
NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA ♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA
NA NA-NA-NA NA-NA ♪
♪ WANNA BE ON TOP ♪♪
♪♪